I've generated over $25 million in
revenue for my clients through
automation. And I'm about to tell you
why learning NAT might be the worst
decision you make this year. Unless you
understand what you're actually getting
yourself into and how to approach it the
right way. You see, most people quit in
week 2. Not because NA10 is hard. It's
because most tutorials are teaching you
the wrong way. First, I'll expose the
raw truth behind YouTube tutorials and
workflows that actually screw you up
instead of saving you time. Then, I'll
show you the real timeline of learning
NA10 and what mistakes to avoid. And if
you stick to the end, I'll reveal the
exact breakthrough moment where you'll
become an NA10 operator. So, let me
start with why most tutorials are
setting you up for failure. Now, let's
say you land your first automation
client tomorrow. They want a simple lead
personalization and follow-up
automation. You confidently quote them
one week because you've seen all the
YouTube tutorials and you've got a bunch
of different workflow templates from X,
but 3 weeks later, you're completely
screwed. The workflow might work fine in
testing, but when you run a bunch of
real data through it, things just don't
seem to go to plan. You've got duplicate
leads, data not mapping to the correct
fields, and a bunch of different errors.
And now you're spending day and night
debugging what should have been a pretty
straightforward, simple SMS and email
workflow. And to be honest, this isn't
your fault. Most of the tutorials that
you see out there are using test data in
a perfect scenario. But nobody shows you
what happens when you run 500 leads into
your workflow instead of the five that
you tested it with. And there's a
specific learning pattern that separates
the ones who can push through versus the
ones who quit. So in week one, you'll
build simple workflows with native
integrations in NA10 like Slack or Gmail
using the AI agent node. You'll feel
pretty good about connecting nodes like
Slack and sending messages through, but
you'll end up running into a ton of
issues. And this is where the real
learning starts. You're going to
discover a bunch of nodes that you have
no idea how to configure. And to be
honest, you'll probably rebuild your
workflows two or maybe three times
because nothing quite works how you
expected. A week two to three is where
things finally start to click into
place. You'll finally build multi-step
workflows with conditional logic and
HTTP requests with API integrations. The
the data flow from node to node will
finally start to make more sense. And
this is where most people get hooked
because they can see the potential. But
on the flip side, you're going to run
into more errors, especially when it
comes to troubleshooting HTTP requests
and those pesky API integrations. Month
two is about getting dangerous. You'll
build custom branching logic, complex AI
agent and system prompts, and even
custom code nodes. But the problem at
this stage is that you'll start to
overengineer simple tasks and workflows.
You'll probably build complex,
unnecessary solutions where a simple
workflow is probably the better option.
So at this stage, very important just to
keep things as simple as possible. So
month three is where you start building
advanced workflows. We're talking sub
agents. We're talking MCP server calls.
We're talking agents with multiple
tools. We're talking knowledge bases,
error handling, and so much more. You're
not just connecting nodes anymore.
You're building fast, reliable
automations that actually work. But even
knowing that timeline won't save you if
you're making these three mistakes that
kill most people's progress. So mistake
number one is tutorial addiction. You'll
watch endless tutorials on YouTube.
You'll save all of the workflows on X,
but you never actually build something
valuable. I hear from so many people in
the DMs who save 30, 40, 50 different
workflows from different creators on X,
but they can't actually put together a
simple lead enrichment workflow from
scratch. They're addicted to learning,
but not doing the hard work in actually
building the thing. So, mistake number
two is complexity worship. So, everybody
wants to build an impressive 30 node
workflow because it's going to look cool
on social media on X or LinkedIn. But
personally, my highest earning
automation is about four or five
different nodes. And it's generated one
of my clients over $600,000 in revenue.
So, that proves that you don't need
something crazy complicated to actually
be valuable and profitable. So, stop
trying to impress people and start
solving expensive problems. So mistake
three, ignoring the business side. So
you can master every node in NA10 and
you can become a technical whiz, but if
you don't understand how to actually
extract painful problems from potential
clients and how to even get in front of
those clients in the first place, all
the skill in the world is not going to
matter because you're not going to be
able to build a business from it and
help other businesses with your skills.
But knowing these mistakes isn't enough.
There's a specific breakthrough moment
that changes everything about how you
approach automation. So when you stop
building workflows and actually start
solving problems, you're going to learn
NA10 5 to 10 times faster. Instead of I
want to learn NA10, ask how can I
automate this $5,000 a month manual
process? Then learn only the nodes
needed for that specific solution or
find a similar template that you can
actually start working from. My
breakthrough came when I stopped
following tutorials and instead I
reverse engineered workflows that are
actually making money for businesses.
And that's how I generated over $25
million for my clients with automation
over the last 8 years. But honestly, I
made countless mistakes on the journey
there. Months of trial and error, broken
workflows, frustrated clients, and you
probably don't have the time for that.
That's why I created the NA10
mentorship. It's designed to help you go
from zero to N810 operator in just 90
days. I'll help you build
productionready workflows, guide you
through how to fix and troubleshoot
problems, and make more money. And my
guarantee is that if you don't have a
productionready workflow up and running
in 30 days, I'll refund every penny.
Now, I'm only taking on 10 new students
this month because I review and speak to
every single student before I decide to
invite them into the mentorship. So,
click the first link in the description
below if you're serious about mastering
automation without spending months and
months trying to figure it all out on
your own. So, thanks for watching and
I'll see you